foreign
hi everyone welcome to this data science
2022 full course video by simply Loan in
this video you will learn all the
necessary skills that will help you
become a data scientist in 2022 our
highly experienced instructors will take
you through this course
data scientists are some of the highly
paid Professionals in the world they
work on data from multiple sources to
derive insights
now let's look at the topics that we'll
be covering in this video
so we will start by looking at the
basics of data science from a short
animated video then you will learn the
data science process steps their
applications and then look at the top
five python libraries for data science
next you will understand the top
algorithms that data scientists use to
build predictive models so you will
learn about linear regression logistic
regression and simple learning methods k
n clustering principle component
analysis and other techniques after that
we will touch upon some of the crucial
Concepts in deep learning using
tensorflow and Keras finally you will
get an idea about the top data science
interview questions that are frequently
Asked in the interviews so let's get
started
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
Emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in a life goes while she's working
on data science project well it is very
important to understand the business
problem first in our meeting with the
clients Emma asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled she
is a curious Soul who asks a lot of eyes
one of the many traits of a good data
scientist now she gears up for data
acquisition to gather and scrape data
from multiple sources like web servers
logs databases apis and online
repositories oh it seems like finding
the right data takes both time and
effort after the data is gathered comes
data preparation this step involves data
cleaning and data transformation data
cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling many
complex scenarios here Emma deals with
inconsistent data types misspelled
attributes missing values duplicate
values and whatnot then in data
transformation she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in a
project
ETL tools like talent and Informatica
are used to perform complex
Transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that Mr does exploratory data analysis
with the help of Eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if Emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
way tables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
modeling she repetitively applies the
type Force machine learning techniques
like k n decision tree knife base to the
data to identify the model that best
fits the business requirement she trains
the models on the training data set and
tests them to select the best performing
model Emma prefers python for modeling
the data however it can also be done
using R and SAS well the trickiest part
is not yet over visualization and
communication Emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders she
uses tools like Tableau power bi and
click view that can help her in creating
powerful reports and
finally maintains the model she tests
the selected model in a pre-production
environment before deploying it in the
production environment which is the best
practice right after successfully
deploying it she uses reports and
dashboards to get real-time analytics
further she also monitors and maintains
the Project's performance well that's
how Emma completes the data science
project we have seen the daily routine
of a data scientist is a whole lot of
fun has a lot of interesting aspects and
comes with its own share of challenges
now let's see how data science is
changing the world data science
techniques along with genomic data
provides a deeper understanding of
genetic issues and reaction to
particular drugs and diseases logistic
companies like DHL FedEx have discovered
the best routes to ship the best suited
time to deliver the best mode of
transport to choose thus leading to cost
efficiency with data science it is
possible to not only predict employee
activation but to also understand the
key variables that influence employee
turnover also the airline companies can
now easily predict flight delay and
notify the passengers beforehand to
enhance their travel experience well if
you're wondering there are various roles
offered to a data scientist like data
analyst machine learning engineer deep
learning engineer data engineer and of
course data scientist the median base
salaries of a data scientist can range
from 95 000 to 165 000 so that was about
the data science are you ready to be a
data scientist if yes then start today
the world of data needs you that's all
from my side today thank you for
watching comment below the next topic
that you want to learn and subscribe to
Simply learn to get the latest updates
on more such interesting videos thank
you and keep learning
so what are the prerequisites for data
science there are three essential traits
required for to be a data scientist one
is curiosity you need to be able to ask
questions the first step in data science
is asking questions what is the problem
we are trying to solve if you ask the
right question only then you'll get the
right answer very often this is a very
crucial step where a lot of data science
projects fail because you're you may be
asking the wrong question and then
obviously when you get the answer that's
not the answer you're looking for so it
is very important that you ask the right
question needless to say then the second
part or the second trait is common sense
so you need to be creative you need to
come up with ways to use the data that
you have and try to solve the business
problem on hand in many cases you may
not have all the data that you need in
many cases the data may be incomplete so
that is where you need to come up with
ways what are the best ways to fill
these gaps where wherever this is
missing and that's where Common Sense
comes into play last but not least after
doing all this analysis if you are
unable to communicate the results in the
right way the whole exercise will fail
so communication is a key trait for a
data scientist maybe technically you may
be a genius but then if you are unable
to communicate those results in a proper
way once again that will not help so
these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense and communication
skills in a way you can say these are
the three C's okay so what are the other
prerequisites the first one so machine
learning machine learning is the
backbone of data science data science
involves quite a bit of machine learning
in addition to the basic statistics that
we do so a data scientist needs to have
a good hang or need to be very good at
data science second part is modeling so
modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way but you need to be
good at identifying what are the
algorithms that are more suitable to
solve a given problem what models can we
use and how do we train these models and
so on and so forth so that is the second
component then statistics statistics is
like the core Foundation of data science
so you need to understand statistics and
you need to have a good hang of
Statistics in order to be a good data
scientist and this will also help in
getting good results programming is to
some extent required at least some
program or the other would be required
as a part of executing a data science
project the most common programming
languages are Python and R python
specially is becoming a very popular
programming language in data science
because of its ease of learning because
of the multiple live libraries that it
supports for performing data science and
machine learning and so on so python is
by far one of the most popular languages
in data science if any one of you is
wanting to learn a new language that
should be Python and then of course you
need to understand databases how
databases work and how to handle
databases how to get data out of
databases and so on so these are some of
the key components of data science now
coming to the tools and skills that are
used in data science these are some of
the skills from a language perspective
it is python or R and from a skills
perspective in addition to some of the
programming languages it would help if
you have a good knowledge or good
understanding of statistics and what are
the tools that are used in data analysis
SAS is one of the most popular tools
it's been there for very long time and
that's the reason it is very popular and
however this is compared to most of the
other tools it is a proprietary software
whereas Python and R are mostly open
source the other tools are like Jupiter
Jupiter notebooks you have rstudio these
are more development environments and
development tools so Jupiter notebooks
is a interactive development environment
similarly our studio is for performing
or writing our code and Performing
analytics and Performing data analysis
and machine learning activities you can
perform in our studio it has a very nice
UI and initially R was not so popular
primarily because it did not have user
interface and our studio is a relatively
new edition and after the Advent of our
studio R became extremely popular and
there are other tools like Matlab and of
course some people do with Excel as well
as far as data warehousing is concerned
some of the skills that are required are
ETL so in order to extract data and
transform low dtl stands for extract
transform load so you have data in the
databases like your Erp system or a CRM
system you need to extract that and then
do some Transformations and then load it
into your Warehouse so that all the data
from various sources looks uniform then
you need some SQL skills which is
basically querying the data writing SQL
queries Hadoop is another important
skill especially if you are handling
large amounts of data also one of the
Specialties of Hadoop is it can be used
for handling the unstructured data as
well so it can be used for large amounts
of structure and unstructured data then
spark is a excellent Computing engine
for performing data analysis or machine
learning in a distributed mode so if you
have large amount of data the
combination of spark and Hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data in Hadoop hdfs and use spark as
your computation engine
it works in a distributed mode similar
to Hadoop if like a cluster so that
those are excellent skills for data
warehousing and there are some standard
tools that are available like
Informatica data stage talent and also
AWS redshift if you want to do some on
the cloud I think AWS redshift is again
a good tool data visualization tools for
data visualization some of the skills
that would be required are let's say are
R provides some very good visualization
capabilities especially for developing
during development and then you have
python libraries matplotlib and so on
which provides very powerful
visualization capabilities and that is
from skills perspective whereas tools
that can be used are Tableau is a very
very popular visualization tool again
that's a proprietary tool so it's a
little expensive maybe but excellent
capabilities from a visualization
perspective then there are tools like
hognose which is an IBM product which
provides very good visualization
capabilities as well and then coming to
the machine learning part of it the
skills required there are python which
is more for programming part and then
you will need some mathematical skills
like algebra linear religious
and then statistics and maybe a little
bit of calculus and so on and the tools
that are used for machine learning are
spark mlib and Apache mahot and on cloud
if you want to do something you can use
Microsoft Azure ml Studio as well so
these are by no means an exhaustive list
there are actually many many tools and
probably a few more skills also maybe
there but this is this gives a quick
overview like a summarizing of
summarization of the tools and skills
now moving on to the life of a data
scientist what does a data scientist do
during the course of his work so let's
see so typically a data scientist is
given a problem a business problem that
he needs to solve and in order to do
that if you remember from the previous
slide he basically asks the question as
to what is the problem that he needs to
solve so that is the first thing he has
got the problem then the next thing is
to gather the data that is required
solve this problem so he goes about
looking for data from anywhere it could
be the Enterprise very often the data is
not provided in the nice format that he
would like to have it or we would like
to have it so first step is to get
whatever data that is possible what is
known as raw data in whatever format so
it could be Enterprise data it could be
it is a probably a requirement to go and
get some public data in some cases so
all that raw data is collected and then
that is processed and analyzed and in
prepared into a format in which it can
be used and then it is fed into the
analytics system be it machine learning
algorithm or statistical model and we
get the output and then he puts these
output in a proper format for presenting
it to the stakeholders and communicating
those insights or the results to the
stakeholder so this is a very high level
View of like a a day in the life of a
data scientist so Gathering data raw
data performing some quick analysis on
that and maybe processing or
manipulating this data to bring it into
a certain good format so that it can be
used for the analysis feeding this into
that analysis system that has been
designed be it mathematical models
machine learning models and then get the
results the insights and then present it
in a nice way so that the stakeholders
can understand
how about machine learning algorithms so
let's see what are the various machine
learning algorithms that would be
required for a data scientist so these
are a few of the algorithms again
there's not an exhaustive list we we
have regression this is one of the
supervised learning models or techniques
so in case of regression you try to
let's say come up with a continuous
number so the difference between
regression and let's say a
classification is that in case of
classification those are discrete values
whereas here we are talking about
regression where you let's say you are
trying to predict the temperature which
is a continuous value or the share price
which is a continuous value so that is
regression so you need to know what is
regression how to perform regression and
we need to understand clustering so
clustering is one of the unsupervised
learning techniques in this case there
is no label data that is available and
you get some data and then you want to
put this into some shape so that you can
analyze it and you try to make sense out
of it let's say you have one example is
you have a list of cricketers and the
not been marked as Bowlers and batsmen
or roll renders or whatever right so you
just have their names and maybe how many
runs they scored how many wickets they
have taken and so on but there is no
readily available information saying
that okay this person is a batsman this
person is a bowler and so on so I'm
talking about Cricket hopefully most of
you are familiar with the game of
cricket so how do we find out so then we
put this into a clustering mechanism and
then the system will say that okay these
are the people who are all who have all
scored good amount of runs so they
belong to one cluster these are all the
people who have taken good amount of
wickets so they belong to one cluster
and maybe here are some people who have
taken good amount of wickets and they
have made good amount of runs so they
may be belonging to one group and then
we take a look at it and then we label
them as okay people who have all
together and those who have you know
scored many runs they are we label them
batsmen people who have taken a lot of
wickets we label them as Bowlers and
people who have taken good amount of
wickets and also made some good runs we
label them as all rounders but the
system will just say okay this is
cluster one cluster two cluster three
the names we give we human beings have
to give the names now decision tree is
used for what is known as classification
primarily it can also be used for
regression but by and large it is used
for classification and here again it's a
very logical way in which the algorithm
goes about classifying the various
inputs one of the biggest advantages of
decision tree is that it's very easy to
understand and it's very easy to explain
why a certain object has been classified
in a certain way compared to maybe some
of the other mechanisms like say support
Vector machines or logistic regression
and so on so that's the advantage of
dictionary but that is also very popular
algorithm then we have support Vector
machines primarily for classification
purpose and then we have knife base this
is again a statistical probability based
classification method so these are a few
algorithms there are a few more that are
not listed here but there are some more
algorithms as well and by the way there
are more detailed or there are detailed
videos about each of these algorithms
available you can check in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step is the concept study in this step
it involves understanding the business
problem asking questions get a good
understanding of the business model meet
up with all the stakeholders understand
what kind of data is available and all
that is a part of the first step so here
are a few examples we want to see what
are the various specifications and then
what is the end goal what is the budget
is there an example of this kind of a
problem that has been maybe solved
earlier so all this is a part of the
concept study and another example could
be a very specific one to predict the
price of a 1.35 carat diamond and there
may be relevant information inputs that
are available and we want to predict the
price the next step in this process is
data preparation data Gathering and data
preparation also known as data munching
or sometimes it is also known as data
manipulation so what happens here is the
raw data that is available may not be
usable in its current format for various
reasons so that is why in this step a
data scientist would explore the data he
will take a look at some sample data
maybe there are millions of Records pick
a few thousand records and see how the
data is looking are there any gaps is
the structure appropriate to be fed into
the system are there some columns which
are probably not adding value may not be
required for the analysis very often
these are like names of the customers
they will probably not add any value or
much value from an analysis perspective
the structure of the data Maybe the data
is coming from multiple data sources and
the structures may not be matching what
are the the problems there may be gaps
in the data so the data all the columns
all the cells are not filled if you're
talking about structured data there are
several blank records or blank columns
so if you use that data directly you'll
get errors or you will get inaccurate
results so how do you either get rid of
that data or how do you fill this gaps
with something meaningful so all that is
a part of data munching or data
manipulation so these are some
additional sub topics within that so
data integration is one of them there
are any conflicts in the data there may
be data may be redundant yeah data
resonant redundancy is another issue
then maybe you have let's say data
coming from two different systems and
both of them have customer table for
example
information so when you merge them there
is a duplication issue so how do we
resolve that so that is what data
transformation as I said there will be
situations where data is coming from
multiple sources and then when we merge
them together they may not be matching
so we need to do some transformations to
make sure everything is similar we may
have to do some data reduction if the
data size is too big you may have to
come up with ways to reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be the
wrong values or your null values or
there are missing values so how do you
handle all of that few examples of very
specific stuff so if there are missing
values how do you handle missing values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value then you
have null value you see the difference
between the two right so in a missing
value there is nothing blank null value
it says null now the system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a string or a non-numeric value so
how do we clean and prepare the data so
that our system can work flawlessly so
there are multiple ways and there is no
one common way of doing this it can vary
from Project to project it can vary from
what exactly is the problem we are
trying to solve it can vary from data
scientist to data scientist organization
to organization so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course there will be a lot of
trial and errors somebody would have
tried out something and it worked and
use that mechanism mechanism so that's
how we need to take care of data
cleaning now what are the various ways
of doing you know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large and only a few records
have some missing values then it is okay
to just get rid of those entire rows for
example so if you have a million records
and out of which 100 records don't have
full data so there are some missing
values in about 100 cards so it's
absolutely fine because it's a small
percentage of the data so you can get
rid of the entire records which are
missing values but that's not a very
common situation very often you will
have multiple or at least you know large
number of a data set for example out of
million records you may have 50 000
records which are like having missing
values now that's a significant amount
you cannot get rid of all those records
your analysis will be inaccurate so how
do you handle such situations so there
are again multiple ways of doing it one
is you can probably if a particular
values are missing in a particular
column you can probably take the mean
value for that particular column and
fill all the missing values with the
mean value so that first of all you
don't get errors because of missing
values and second you don't get results
that are way off because these values
are completely different from what is
there so that is one way then few other
could be either taken the median value
or depending on what kind of data we are
talking of so something meaningful we
will have put in there if we are doing
some machine learning activity then
obviously as a part of data preparation
you need to split the data into training
and test data set the reason being if
you try to test with a data set which
the system has already seen as a part of
training then it will tend to give a
reasonably accurate results because it
has already seen that data and that is
not a good measure of the accuracy of
the system so typically you take the
entire data set the input data set and
split it into two parts and again the
ratio can vary from person to person
individual preferences some people like
to split it into 50 50 some people like
it has
63.33 and 33.3 is basically two third
and one-third and some people do it as
80 20 80 for training and 20 for testing
so you split the data perform the
training with the 80 percent and then
use the remaining 20 for testing all
right so that is one more data
preparation activity that needs to be
done before you start analyzing or
applying the data or putting the data
through the model then the next step is
model planning now this models can be
statistical models this could be machine
learning models so you need to decide
what kind of models you're going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regular Direction algorithm and come
up with a regression model so it could
be linear regression or if you are
talking about classification then you
need to pick up an appropriate
classification algorithm like logistic
regression or decision tree or svm and
then you need to train that particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process and the cleaned
up data has to be fed into the model and
apart from cleaning you may also have to
in order to determine what kind of model
you will use you have to perform some
exploratory data analysis to understand
the relationship between the various
variables and see if the data is
appropriate and so on right so that is
the additional preparatory step that
needs to be done so little bit of
details about exploratory data analysis
so what exactly is exploratory data
analysis is basically to as the name
suggests you're just exploring you just
receive the data and you're trying to
explore and find out what are the data
types and what is the is the data clean
in in each of the columns what is the
maximum minimum value so for example
there are out of the box functionality
available in tools like R so if you just
ask for a summary of the table it will
tell you for each column it will give
some details as to what is the mean
value what is the maximum value and so
on and so forth so this exercise or this
exploratory analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to during this process
you find there are a lot of missing
values you need to take steps to fix
those you will also get an idea about
what kind of model to be used and so on
and so forth what are the various
techniques used for exploratory data
analysis typically these would be
visualization techniques like you use
histograms you can use box plots you can
use Scatter Plots so these are very
quick ways of identifying the patterns
or a few of the trends of the data and
so on and then once your data is ready
you you've decided on the model what
kind of model what kind of algorithm
you're going to use if you are trying to
do machine learning you need to pass
your 80 percent training data or rather
you use the training data to train your
model and the training process itself is
iterative so the training process you
may have to perform multiple times and
once the training is done and you feel
it is giving good accuracy then you move
on to test so you take the remaining 20
of the data remember we split the data
into training and test so the test data
is now used to check the accuracy or how
well our model is performing and if
there are further issues let's say a
model is still during testing in the
accuracy is not good then you may want
to retrain your model or use a different
model so this whole thing again can be
iterative but if the test process is
passed or if the model passes the test
then it can go into production and it
will be deployed all right so what are
the various tools that we use for model
planning R is an excellent tool in a lot
of ways whether you're doing regular
statistical analysis or machine learning
or any of these activities are in along
with our studio provides a very powerful
environment to do data analysis
including visualization it has a very
good integrated visualization or plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then later
on to do analysis detailed analysis and
machine learning and so on and so forth
then of course you can write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis and machine
learning and so on Matlab is a very
popular tool as well especially during
education so this is a very easy to
learn tool so Matlab is another tool
that can be used and then last but not
least SAS SAS is again very powerful it
is proprietary tool and it has all the
components that are required to perform
very good statistical analysis or
perform data science so those are the
various tools that would be required for
or that that can be used for model
building and so the next step is model
building so we have done the planning
part we said okay what is algorithm we
are going to use what kind of model we
are going to use now we need to actually
train this model or build the model
rather so that it can then be deployed
so what are the various uh ways or what
are the various types of model building
activities so it could be let's say in
this particular example that we have
taken you want to find out the price of
1.35 carat diamond so this is let's say
a linear regression problem you have
data for various carrots of diamond and
you use that information you pass it
through a linear regression model that
you create action model which can then
predict your price for 1.35 carat so
this is one example of model building
and then a little bit details of how
linear regression works so linear
regression is basically coming up with a
relation between an independent variable
and a dependent variable so it is pretty
much like coming up with equation of a
straight line which is the best fit for
the given data so like for example here
Y is equal to MX plus C so Y is the
dependent variable and X is the
independent variable we need to
determine the values of M and C for our
given data so that is what the training
process of this model does at the end of
the training process you have a certain
value of M and c and that is used for
predicting the values of any new data
that comes all right so the way it works
is we use the training and the test data
set to train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using test data and if it is working
fine then it is taken to the next level
which is put in production if not the
model has to be retrained if the QSC is
not good enough then the model is
retrained maybe with more data or you
come up with a newer model or algorithm
and then repeat that process so it is an
iterative process once the training is
completed training and test then this
model is deployed and we can use this
particular model to determine what is
the price of 1.35 carat diamond remember
that was our problem statement so now
that we have the best fit for this given
data we have the price of 1.35 carat
diamond which is 10 000. so this is one
example of how this whole process works
now how do we build the model there are
multiple ways you can use Python for
example and use libraries like pandas or
numpy to build a model and implement it
this will be available as a separate
tutorial a separate video in this
playlist so stay tuned for that moving
on once we have the results the next
step is to communicate this results to
the appropriate stakeholders so which is
basically taking this results and
preparing like a presentation or a
dashboard and communicating these
results to the concerned people so
finishing or getting the results of the
analysis is not the last step but you
need to as a data scientist take this
results and present it to the team that
has given you this problem in the first
place and explain your findings explain
the findings of this exercise and
recommend maybe what steps they need to
take in order to overcome this problem
or solve this problem so that is the
pretty much once that is accepted and
the last step is to operationalize so if
everything is fine your data scientists
presentations are accepted then they put
it into practice and thereby they will
be able to improve or solve the problem
that they stated in step one okay so
quick summary of the life cycle you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem asking the
right questions and trying to see if
there is enough data to solve this
problem and then even maybe gather the
data then data preparation the raw data
needs to be manipulated you need to do
data munging so that you have a data in
a certain proper format to be used by
the model or our analytics system and
then you need to do the model planning
what kind of a model what algorithm you
will use for a given problem and then
the model building so the exact
execution of that model happens in step
four and you implement and execute that
model and put the data through the
analysis in this step and then you get
the results this results are then
communicated packaged and presented and
communicated to the stakeholders and
once that is accepted that is
operationalized so that that is the
final step now in the end let's take a
quick look at the demand for data
scientists data science is an area of
great demand the demand for data
scientists is currently huge and the
supply is very low so there is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists I
think gaming is definitely one area
where it's a industry which is consumer
facing industry and a lot of people play
games and growing industry and it
requires a lot of data science so that
is an area where data scientists are in
demand then we have health care for
example data science is used for
diagnosis and several other activities
within Healthcare predicting for example
heart disease so Healthcare is
definitely Finance definitely Banks
insurance companies all of these there
is a huge demand for data scientists
marketing is like a horizontal
functionality across all Industries
there's a demand for data scientists
there then of course in technology area
so pretty much all of these areas that
is a lot of demand globally there is a
huge demand so this is a very very
critical skill that would be required
currently as well as in the future
talk about solving problems with data
data ants we have to ask possible
questions and the desired algorithms and
these really are kind of an overview of
some of the terminology you'll want to
know in data science so we talk about
that how much or how many we're talking
about regression regression basically
means a number if you've ever seen stock
charts you see the guess at what the
next sales price is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it ARB classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how different is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in where are
the outliers what are things we might
need to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest Market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning a lot of times when you put
your model together you might have
multiple parts of this we might look at
the clustering of data and then feed it
into a classification is this a bad loan
to make it the bank or is this a good
loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person should
be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then a lot of the models
reinforce learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning uh now we're starting to
automate that so that as the data comes
in real time the models start updating
themselves they start figuring out a way
to solve new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
Fields logarithms used in data science
linear regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these think numbers we're
talking regression models and so linear
regression figures out the best line
through the data Maybe it's looking for
a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data on a Continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool if you used
to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors okay nearest neighbors
is your clustering K means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them and builds a
hierarchy where the K means and the K
nearest neighbor look for things that
kind of connect each other how close are
they in data format
DB scan another form of clustering your
data principal component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with to build a better model to
predict your data and where you want it
to go python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience most data
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python every day
hi I'm a baksha from Simply learn and
well after some thought and a bit more
research I was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top python libraries
for data science what are they let's
find out so let's talk about this
amazing Library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35
000 top comments and a Vibrant Community
of around 1500 contributors and it's
used across various scientific domains
it's basically a framework where we can
Define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can say
are partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly
used in deep learning models and neural
networks where we have other libraries
like torch and thiano also but
tensorflow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensorflow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in neural machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where it
can train multiple neural networks and
multiple gpus for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel Computing
feature of tensorflow is also called
pipelining also tensorflow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by Google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features now let's look at
some applications tensorflow is
extensively used in speech and image
recognition text-based applications time
series analysis and forecasting and
various other applications involving
video detection so favorite thing about
tensorflow that it's already popular
among the machine learning community and
most are open to trying it and some of
us are already using it now let's look
at an example of a tensorflow model in
this example we will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we're using amnest dataset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
Library the inputs will look something
like this then we create our tensorflow
model to create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 percent accuracy let's see
which is pretty well for this model so
that's all for tensorflow if you need to
understand this tutorial in detail then
you can go ahead and watch our deep
learning tutorial from Simply learn as
shown in the right corner interesting
right let's move on to the next library
now let's talk about a common yet a very
powerful python Library called numpy
numpy is a fundamental package for
numerical competition in Python it
stands for numerical python as the name
suggests it has around 18 000 comments
on GitHub with an active community of
700 contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now now let's talk
about features of numbai it's very easy
to work with large arrays and mattresses
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to ndre once again it's a class
possessing numerous methods and
attributes ndra provides for larger and
repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods I
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci-fi psychic learn
Etc when you start creating the machine
learning models in data science you will
realize that all the models will have
their basis numpy or pandas also when
numpa is used with sci-fi and matplotlib
it can be used as a replacement of
Matlab now let's look at a simple
example of an array in numpy as you can
see here there are multiple array
manipulation routines like their basic
examples where you can copy the values
from one array to another we can give a
new shape to an array from maybe one
dimensional do we can make it as a two
dimensional array we can return a copy
of the array collapse into one dimension
now let's look at an example where this
is Jupiter notebook and we will just
create a basic array and for detailed
explanation you can watch our other
videos which Targets on these
explanations of each libraries so first
of all whenever we are using any library
in Python we have to import it so now
this NP is the Alias which we will be
using let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an indiary type of array Also
let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create an array
using arrange functions if I give
arrange 12 it will give me a 1D array of
12 numbers like this now we can reshape
this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how arrange function and the
reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next Library which is
Sci Pi so this is another free and open
source python Library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this Library as the name
suggests stands for Scientific Python
and it has around 19 000 commits on
GitHub with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and Technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
sci-fi so sci-fi has a collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of scipy now let's discuss
its applications so cyber is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into numpy arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images
Etc solving differential equations
Fourier transforms then optimization
algorithms linear algebra Etc let's look
at a simple example to learn what kind
of functions are there in sci-fi here
I'm importing the constants package of
scipy Library so in this package it has
all the constants
so here I'm just mentioning C or H or n
a and this Library already knows what it
has to fetch like speed of light
Planck's constant Etc so this can be
used in further calculations data
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munching and then
cleaning the data also hence mention of
pandas is a must in data science life
cycle yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comets on
GitHub and an active community of 1200
contributors it is heavily used for data
analysis in cleaning as it provides fast
flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so pandas offers this
eloquent syntax and Rich functionalities
like there are various methods in pandas
like Drop n a fill any which gives you
the freedom to deal with missing data
also Partners provides a powerful apply
function which lets you create your own
function and run it across a series of
data now forget about writing those four
Loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
C then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so panas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling in data cleaning then pandas
also Finds Its usage in ETL jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading CSV
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and Commercial domains including
statistics Finance Neuroscience
economics web analytics Etc then pandas
is also very useful in Time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting Etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here I'm only enlisting important
libraries and data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
I'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this before using pandas here I'm
importing the pandas Library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a CSV file Excel
files there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into Data frame so
here I am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also I'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so PD is the Alias we've given
pandas random data of 6x4 index which is
taking a range 6 numbers and column name
I'm giving as ABCD now let's go ahead
and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names ABCD my list has six
numbers 0 to 5 and a random data four so
data frame is just another table with
rows and columns where you can do
various functions over it also I can go
ahead and describe this data frame to
see so it's giving me all these
functionalities where count and mean and
standard deviation
Etc okay so that was about pandas now
let's talk about next library and last
one so matplotlib for me is the most fun
Library out of all of them why because
it has such powerful yet beautiful
visualizations we'll see in the coming
slides plot and mac.lib suggest that
it's a plotting library for python it
has around 26 000 comets on GitHub and a
very Vibrant Community of 700
contributors and because of such graphs
and plots that it produces it's majorly
used for data visualization and also
because it provides an object all
oriented API which can be used to embed
those plots into our applications let's
talk about the features of matplotlib
the pi plot module of matplotlab
provides matlab-like interface so
matplotlib is designed to be as usable
as Matlab with an advantage of being
free and open source also it supports
dozens of backends and output types
which means you can use it regardless of
which operating system you are using or
which output format you wish pandas
itself can be used as wrappers around
matplotlips API so as to drive Mac
broadly via cleaner and more modern apis
also when you start using this Library
you will realize that it has a very
little memory consumption and a very
good runtime Behavior now let's talk
about the applications of matplotlib
it's important to discover the unknown
relationship between the variables in
your data set so this Library helps to
visualize the correlation analysis of
variables also in machine learning we
can visualize 95 confidence interval of
the model just to communicate how well
model fits the data then matpatliff
Finds Its application in outlier
detection using scatter plot Etc and to
visualize the distribution of data to
gain instant insights now let's make a
very simple plot to get a basic idea
I've already imported the libraries here
so this function matplotlib inline will
help you show the plots in the Jupiter
notebook this is also called a magic
function I won't be able to display my
plots in the jupyter notebook if I don't
use this function I am using this
function in numpy to fix random state
for reproducibility now I'll take my n
as 30 and will assign random values to
my variables so this function is
generating 30 random numbers here I am
trying to create a scatter plot so I
want to decide the area let's put this
so just multiplying 30 with random
numbers to the power 2 so that we get
the area of the plot which we will see
in just a minute so using the scatter
function and the Alias of matplot web as
PLT I've created this if I don't use
this in a very small circles as my
scatter plot it's colorful it's nice so
that's one very easy plot I suggest that
you Explore More of matplotlib and I'm
sure you will enjoy it let's create a
histogram so I'm using my the style is
GG plot and assigning some values to
these variables any random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
Alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work on them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow Keras is another popular
Library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
Keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
back-ends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit-learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sci-fi then we have c bond which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that c bone is an enhancement
of matplotlib as it introduces
additional plot types
and let's understand linear regression
and dig into the theory understanding
linear regression linear regression is
the statistical model used to predict
the relationship between independent and
dependent variables by examining two
factors the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals m times X plus C and if you look
at our model here we plotted two points
on here X1 and y1 X2 and Y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that that
from before and next being the
independent variable so y depends on
whatever X is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the Y2 minus y1 and X2
minus X1 and finally we have C which is
the coefficient of the line or where it
happens to cross the zero axes let's go
back and look at an example we used
earlier of linear regression we're going
to go back to plotting the amount of
crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y-axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the Green Dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on that we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes
I want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable X and our dependent variable Y
and when X was 1 we got y equals 2 when
X was 2 y was 4 and so on and so on if
we go ahead and plot this data on a
graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is with the means is of each of the
data coming in the X and the Y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average so we add up all the numbers and
divide by the total so one plus two plus
three plus four plus five over five
equals three and the same for y we get
four if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get three
comma four which draws a nice line down
the middle a good estimate here we're
going to dig deeper into the math behind
the regression line now remember before
I said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whiz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the X Y points
and create all all the information you
need so in the top half you can see
where we've broken that down into pieces
and as it goes through the first two
points it computes the squared value of
x the squared value of y and x times Y
and then it takes all of X and adds them
up all of Y adds them up all of x
squared adds them up and so on and so on
and you can see we have the sum of equal
to 15 the sum is equal to 20. all the
way up to x times Y where the sum equals
66. this all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times X plus the
coefficient C so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
Computing it line by line instead of
trying to you have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x times Y which
we computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 times 20. and on
the bottom we have the number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as 86 for the sum minus I'll
take all that and subtract the sum of x
squared and we end up as we come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer you don't have to do the
math on a piece of paper or calculator
and you'll get a slope of 0.6 and you'll
get your C coefficient if you continue
to follow through that formula you'll
see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes let's find out the
predicted values of Y for corresponding
values of X using the linear equation
where m equals 0.6 and C equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1 plus 2.2
equals 2.8 and so on and so on and here
the Blue Points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors the best fit line
should have the least sum of squares of
these errors also known as e-square if
we put these into a nice chart we can
see X and you can see Y what the actual
values were and you can see why it
predicted you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
Square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has a least squared distance between the
data points and the regression line now
we only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc which you want to take away from
this is whatever formula is being used
you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point
Point we've only been looking at two
values X and Y well in the real world
it's very rare that you only have two
values when you're figuring out a
solution so let's move on to the next
topic multiple linear regression let's
take a brief look at what happens when
you have multiple inputs so in multiple
linear regression we have well we'll
start with the simple linear regression
where we had y equals M plus X plus C
and we're trying to find the value of y
now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in so
instead of having just X we have X1 X2
X3 and instead of having just one slope
each variable has its own slope attached
to it as you can see here we have M1 M2
M3 and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the r d we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data to see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
live libraries now I'm going to be doing
this in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy it because it's such
a visual to look at it's so easy to use
just any ID for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python IDE so here we are in our Jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries were
importing first we're going to import
numpy as NP and then I want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as PD
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as NP and you have to
almost have that for your SK learn
toolbox so you always import that right
off the beginning pandas although you
don't have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
I'll show you what that looks like the
other three line lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT and then
Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then Seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the Seaborn is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber signed matplot Library
inline that is only because I'm doing an
inline IDE my interface in the Anaconda
Jupiter notebook requires I put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the I location and
because this is companies as a PD data
set I can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the the values set into
there so X is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is so I can see the
data to me it doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
Investments and you understand what 165
349.20 compared to the administration
cost of 136
897.80 so and so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display and you could
display it to a file in other means and
that's the matplot library in line with
the Amber sign at the beginning so here
we come down to the single line of code
Seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spinning we have Administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with Administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is R and D
spending column one which is
Administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
State and you'll see under State we have
New York California Florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process New York it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that New York California and
Florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in Brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the X also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or a one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
encode or categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take X and
we take y we've already created those X
has the columns with the data in it and
Y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting so setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this where we had this
long formula on the bottom and we were
doing all this summarization and then we
also looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fet in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when I run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals True
Fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a why
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict X test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
I'm in Jupiter in line I can just put
the variable up there and when I hit the
Run button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when I run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into and where it's coming from you can
see the formula down here where y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 and so on
and so on plus C the coefficient so
these variables fit right into this
formula y equals slope one times column
one variable plus slope two times column
two variable all the way to the m into
the n and x to the N plus C the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of two etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the Y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model could remember it does have
a random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression
so where does logistic regression fit
into the overall machine learning
process machine learning is divided into
two types mainly two types there is a
third one called reinforcement learning
but we will not talk about that right
now so one is supervised learning and
the other is unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning uses techniques
like clustering and Association and
supervised learning users techniques
like classification and regression now
supervised learning is used when you
have labeled data you have historical
data then you use supervised learning
when you don't have labeled data then
you used unsupervised learning it's in
supervised learning there are two types
of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion I hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
point reclassification so that is known
as multi-class classifications so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few addition trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have K nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as I
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the X and Y axis X is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and for for the
number of years and when the car broke
down and what was the probability and
that has been plotted along X and Y axis
so this provides an idea or from this
graph we can find find out whether your
car will break down or not we'll see how
so first of all the probability can go
from zero to one as you all aware
probability can be between 0 and 1 and
as we can imagine it is intuitive as
well as the number of years are on the
Lower Side maybe one year two years or
three years till after the service the
chances of your car breaking down are
very limited right so for example
chances of your car breaking down or the
probability of your car breaking down
within two years of your last service
are 0.1 probability similarly three
years is maybe 0.3 and so on but as the
number of years increases let's say if
it was six or seven years there is
almost a certainty that your car is
going to break down that is what this
graph shows so this is an example of a
application of the classification
algorithm and we will see in little
details how exactly logistic regression
is applied here one more thing needs to
be added here is that the dependent
variables outcome is discrete so if we
are talking about whether the car is
going to break down or not so that is a
discrete value the Y that we are talking
about the dependent variable that we are
talking about what we are looking at is
whether the car is going to break down
or not yes or no that is what we are
talking about so here the outcome is
discrete and not a continuous way so
this is how the logistic regression
curve looks let me explain a little bit
what exactly how exactly we are going to
uh determine the class or the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so it can cause
confusion so let's try to remove the
confusion so what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again an algorithm for supervised
learning however here you are going to
find a continuous value you are going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property it
could be your height how much height
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the HR
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is string and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employee's information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be done so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5000
5600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or a no these are
discrete values right so this way you
are trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on this scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out if that is
the discrete problem right a yes or no
kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or Beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at 0 and 1. but still this
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is a probability of the event
happening probability of the person
getting a promotion and divided by the
probability of the person not getting a
promotion that is 1 minus p
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
Infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes 1 then the value of
the odds is 1 by 0 that will be Infinity
but the probability itself remains
between 0 and 1. now this is how an
equation of a straight line love so Y is
equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0
is the y-intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of p x by 1 minus p x
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of PX we will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 X so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression and all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from each other let's go
back so linear regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and linear regression
helps to estimate the dependent variable
when there is a change in the
independent variable whereas here in
case of logistic regression it helps to
calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests is a straight line that's
right or linear regression whereas
logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is s it's an s-shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction whether it's going to rain or
not rain now keep in mind both are used
in weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not it is going to
snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are multi
class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
Binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
Health Care plastic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
drama score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into jupyter notebook and show the
code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an eight by eight image and
there the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to predict what this number is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
listen with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model till we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with the
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the confusion Matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our exam sample
we get an accuracy of about 0.94 which
is pretty good or 94 which is pretty
good all right so what is the confusion
Matrix this is an example of a confusion
Matrix and this is used for identifying
the accuracy of a classification model
or like a logistic regression model so
the most important part in a confusion
Matrix is that first of all this as you
can see this is a matrix and the size of
the Matrix depends on how many outputs
we
so the most important part here is that
the model will be most accurate when we
have the maximum numbers in its diagram
like in this case that's why it has
almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonals should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagnose the cells other than the
diagonal should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a two here there are there's a one
here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed are rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this Matrix how to use this
confusion Matrix I know the name uh is a
little funny sounding confusion Matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straightforward so you are
just plotting what has been predicted
and what is the labeled information or
what is the actual data that's also
known as the ground truth sometimes okay
these are some fancy terms that are used
so predicted label and the actual name
that's on that's all right okay yeah so
we are showing a little bit more
information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and
the predicted value and the actual value
is is exactly the same whereas in this
case right it has there are I think 37
plus five yeah 42 have been fed the
images 42 images are of Digit 3 and the
accuracy is only 37 of them have been
accurately predicted three of them have
been predicted as number seven and two
of them have been predicted as number
eight and so on and so forth okay all
right so with that let's go into Jupiter
notebook and see how the code looks so
this is the code in in jupyter Notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is train our model to recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correct
or not so let's get started so the first
part is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
okay if we take a look this is how the
shape is 1797 by 64. these are like
eight by eight images so that's that's
what is reflected in this shape now from
here onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the images this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see how well it
is able to recognize so the way it works
is the pixel information so as you can
see here this is an eight by eight pixel
kind of a image and the each pixel
whether it is activated or not activated
that is the information available for
each pixel now based on the pattern of
this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels this will be
identified as a zero for example right
similarly as you can see so overall each
of these numbers actually has a
different pattern of the pixel
activation and that's pretty much that
our model needs to learn for which a
number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and tests so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and why
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is a labeled data for each of
them each of the observations we already
have the label information saying
whether this digit is a zero or a one or
a two so that that's this is what will
be used for comparison to to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is
1383 by 64 and Y underscore train has
1383 because there is nothing like the
second part is not required here and
then X underscore test shape we see is
four one four so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression Library and which is
a part of scikit-learn so we we don't
have to implement the logistic
regression process itself we just call
these uh the function and let me go
ahead and execute that so that we have
the logistic regression Library imported
now we create an instance of logistic
regression right so logistic regr is uh
is an instance of logistic regression
and then we use that for training our
model so let me first execute this code
so these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model and then the
second line is where we are passing our
data the training data set and this is
our the the predictors and this is our
Target we are passing this data set to
train our model all right so once we do
this in this case the data is not large
but by and large and the training is
what takes usually a lot of time so we
spend and in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image and uh we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 seems to be fine so let me just
go ahead and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has uh performed so we use the
score method to find what is the
percentages of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94 percent
accurate okay so that's on this part now
what we can also do is we can also see
this accuracy using what is known as a
confusion Matrix so let us go ahead and
try that as well so that we can also
visualize how well this model has done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and um we we
basically create a confusion Matrix and
in instance of confusion matrix by
running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
so okay and first of all the total sum
of all the numbers in this whole Matrix
is equal to the number of observations
in the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in that test data set
and then out of that the maximum number
of them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way using a heat map so we
will create a heat map with some We'll
add some colors as well it's uh it's
like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks and as
you can see here the diagonals again are
all the values are here most of the
values so which means reasonably this
seems to be reasonably accurate and yeah
basically the accuracy score is 94 this
is calculated as I mentioned by adding
all these numbers divided by the total
test value so the total number of
observations in test data set okay so
this is the confusion Matrix for
logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of 9. so this has also been
predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images
need for confusion matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories most error measures
will tell us the total error in our
model but we cannot use it to find out
individual instances of errors in our
models so you have your input coming in
you have your classifier it measures the
error and it says oh 53 of these are
correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53 correct uh on guessing
on the spam is it 23 guessing on spam
and 27 guessing on what's not spam
this is where the confusion Matrix comes
in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems if there is a
significant class imbalance a model
might predict the majority class for all
cases and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted 8 out of 10
instances and we'll have accuracy of 80
percent but is it classifying correctly
a confusion Matrix represents a table
layout of the different outcomes of
prediction
and results of a classification problem
and helps visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our simple
chart predicted and actual the confusion
Matrix helps us identify the correct
predictions of a model for different
individual classes as well as the errors
so you'll see here that the values
predicted by our classifier are along
the rows this is what we're going to
guess it is or our model is guessing
what this is based on its training so
we've already trained the model to guess
whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value it's
supposed to be
people who can speak English will be
classified as positives so because they
have a remember zero one do you speak
English yes no and you could extend this
that they might have do you speak uh
French do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these people who cannot speak
English will be classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so you know zero
ones
the number of times are actual positive
values are equal to predicted positive
values gives us true positive TP the
number of times are actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative TN
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
FP
and you'll see when you're working with
these a lot you know memorizing that
it's false positive you can easily
figure out what that is and pretty soon
you're just looking at the FP or the TP
depending on what you're working on and
the numbers times our model wrongly
predicts positive values as negatives
and gives us a false negative FP
now I'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about cancer
uh do you really want a bunch of false
negatives
you want zero under false negative
so when we look at this confusion Matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have twenty percent
false positives because they go in and
test it in zero false negatives
let's say it might be true if you're
working on uh say a car driving is this
a safe place for the car to go well you
really don't want any false positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on this chart suddenly has huge value we
were talking about spam email how many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in that you want
to be a a true a false negative you
don't want it to go in the spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion Matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier there are four main
metrics accuracy precision recall and F1
score the F1 score is the one I usually
hear the most and accuracy is usually
what you put on your chart when you're
sending in front of the shareholders how
accurate is it people understand
accuracy
F1 score is a little bit more on the
math side and so you got to be a little
careful when you're quoting F1 scores in
the when you're sitting there with all
the shareholders because a lot of them
will just glaze over so confusion Matrix
metrics are performance measures which
help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values it tells us how often our
classifier is right it is the sum of all
True Values divided by the total values
and this makes sense uh again it's one
of those things
I don't want to fall you know it depends
on what you're looking for are you
looking for uh not to miss any spam
mails are you looking to drive down the
road and not run anybody over
precision
is used to calculate the model's ability
to classify positive values correctly it
answers the question when the model
predicts a positive value how often is
it right it is the true positive divided
by the total number of predicted
positive values again in this one
depends on what project you're working
on whether this is what you're going to
be focusing on
uh so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values how often does the model actually
predict the correct positive values
it is a true positive divided by the
total number of actual positive values
and then your F1 score it is the
harmonic mean of recall and precision it
is useful when you need to take both
precision and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
Matrix derived from two different
classifier to figure out which one
performs better we can find the
confusion Matrix for both of them
and you can see we're back to uh does it
classify whether they can speak English
or or non-speaker they speak something
they don't I know the English language
and so we put these two uh confusion
matrixes out here we can go ahead and do
the math behind that we can look up the
accuracy that's a tpn plus TN over the
TF plus TN plus FP plus FN and so we get
an accuracy of 0.8125
and we have a Precision if you do the
Precision which is your TP truth
positive over TP plus FP
we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your TP over TP
plus FN
and then of course your F1 score which
is two times Precision times recall over
Precision plus recall
and we get the 0.857
and if we do that with another model
let's say we have two different models
and we're trying to see which one we
want to use for whatever reason we might
go ahead and compute the same things we
have our accuracy our precision and our
recall and our F1 score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy because that's
really what we're interested in is uh
how many people are we able to classify
as being able to speak English I really
don't want to know if I'm you know I I
really don't want to know if they're
non-speakers
um I'd rather Miss 10 people speaking
English instead of 15. and so you can
see from these charts we probably go
with the first model because it does a
better job guessing who speaks English
and has a higher accuracy because in
this case that is what we're looking for
so uh with that we'll go ahead and pull
up a demo so you can see what this looks
like in the python uh setup in in the
actual coding for this we'll go into
Anaconda Navigator if you're not
familiar with Anaconda it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos
and for quick development as a data
scientist I just love the package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup but in
general you can do just about anything
in here with your python
and for this we'll go with Jupiter
notebook Jupiter lab is the same as
Jupiter notebook you'll see they now
have integration with pi charm if you
work in pi charm uh certainly there's a
lot of other Integrations that Anaconda
has and we've opened up
um I simply learned files I work on and
create a new file called confusion
Matrix demo and the first thing we want
to note is the data we're working with
here I've opened it up in a word pad or
notepad or whatever
you can see it's got a row of uh headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then I saved this in the same file
so I don't have to remember what path
I'm working on uh of course if you have
your data separated and you're working
with a lot of data you probably want to
put it into a different folder or file
depending on what you're doing
and the first thing we want to do is go
ahead and import our tools we're going
to use the pandas that's our data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review Panda's
data frame going to Simply learn you can
pull up the pandas data frame
tutorial on there
and then we're going to use a the scikip
framework which is all denoted as
sklearn and I can just pull this in you
can see here's the scikit dash learn.org
with the stable version that you can
import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model that's our actual
machine learning model we're using and
then with this core this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score the confusion Matrix and
the classifier report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here so
we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read CSV
and then just because we're in jupyter
Notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here a lot of times we'll
actually let me just do this I prefer to
do the just the head of the date or the
top part
and you can see we have age sex I'm not
sure what CP stands for test BPS
cholesterol so a lot of different
measurements if you were in this domain
you'd want to know what all these
different measurements mean
I don't want to focus on that too much
because
when we're talking about data science a
lot of times you have no idea what the
data means if you've ever looked up the
breast cancer measurement it's just a
bunch of measurements and numbers uh
unless you're a doctor you're gonna have
no idea what those measurements mean
but if it's your specialty in your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create Y and it's
going to we're going to set it equal to
the Target so here's our Target value
here
and it's either one or zero
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false what do
you have you have a classifier
and then our X is going to be uh
everything except for the Target so
we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals one remember that's
columns versus the index or rows X is
equal to zero would would give you an
error but you would drop like row two
and then we'll go ahead and just print
that out so you can see what we're
looking at and uh here we have Y data X
data and you can see from the X data we
have the X head and we can go ahead and
just do print
the Y head data and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far if there's a confusion
in there go back and rewind the tape and
review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our X train X test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data before we do the
scalar and the reason is is that you
want the scalar on the training data to
be set on the training data data or fit
to it but not on the test data think of
this as being out in the field you're
not it could actually alter your results
uh so it's always important to do make
sure whatever you do to the training
data or whatever fit you're doing is
always done on the training not on the
test and then we want to go ahead and
scale the data
now we are working with linear
regression model and I'll mention this
here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
so some sometimes you don't need to
scale when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact
uh but we're going to go ahead and take
here's our X train X test y train y test
we create our scalar we go ahead and
scale uh the scale is going to fit the X
train
and then we're going to go ahead and
take our X train and transform it and
then we also need to take our X test and
transform it based on the scale on here
so that our X is now between that nice
minus one to one and so this is all our
pre data setup
and
hopefully all of that looks fairly
familiar to you if you've done a number
of our other classes and you're up to
the setup on here
and then we want to go ahead and do is
create our model and we're going to use
a logistic regression model
and from the logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our X
train and Y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
and so let's go ahead and run that and
so now we are we actually have like our
X test and our prediction so if you
remember from
our Matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction and how those
compare
and if I take us back up here you're
going to notice that we imported the
accuracy score the confusion Matrix and
the classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and I did mention it's going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic Mass standard
regression models and I'd have to look
it up for the logistic regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases uh but if you're in a
neural network and you're there's a lot
of other different setups then you
really want to take this and fit that on
there
and so we can go in and do the accuracy
uh and this is if you remember correctly
we were looking at the accuracy
with the English speaking uh so this is
saying our accuracy as to whether this
person is I believe this is the heart
data set
um
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person's going
to have a heart condition
or the one as it comes up with the zero
one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion Matrix and let me just do
that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here
um here's our 25
uh
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide I'll
just bring this over so it's a nice
visual we have our true positive false
positive
so we had 25 which were true that it
said hey this person is going to be high
risk at heart and we had four that were
still high risk that has said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85 out of 29 people
it was correct on 25 of them and so uh
here's our accuracy score we were just
looking at that our accuracy is your
true positive and your true negative
over all of them how true is it and
there was our accuracy coming up here
0.85 and then we have our nice Matrix
generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
Matrix we had going for that from the
slide and this starts to let's just
start asking questions at this point
um so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at this data here and
saying well
is this good enough is uh this number of
people and hopefully you'd have a much
larger data set in my is my confusion
Matrix showing for the true positive and
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing uh and of course if
you're going to put together whatever
data you're putting out you might want
to separate the true negative false
positive false negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion Matrix and then of course the
Ravel part lets you set that up so you
can just split that right up into a nice
Tuple and the final thing we want to
show you here in the coding on this part
is the confusion Matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the Matrix equals classification report
the Y test and the predict
and then we're going to take that
classification report and go ahead and
print that out
and you can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average your weighted average you have
your Precision your recall your F1 score
and your support all in one window so
you can start looking at this data and
saying oh okay our precision's at 0.83
uh 0.87 for getting a a positive and
0.83 for the negative site for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use and
when we're looking at heart attack
prediction we're only looking at one
aspect what's the chances of this person
having a heart attack or not you might
have something where we went back to the
languages maybe you also want to know
whether they speak English or Hindi or
French and you can see right here that
we can now take our confusion Matrix and
just expand it as big as we need to
depending on how many different
classifiers we're working on
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
currents or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is a diameter greater than two if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression when we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side High height is
less than 10 true or false and as you
see as we split it the entropy continues
to be less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node Leaf node carries a
classification or the decision so it's a
final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animals the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math you don't really have to memorize
this math just be aware that it's there
and this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case let's say it's the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight log base two one over
eight and plus two 2 over 8 of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we plug
that into our computer or calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using height as the condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes of
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to be pay their
loan or not for this bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the Jupiter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just a basic tree
function that's needed for the decision
tree classifier and finally we're going
to load our data down here and I'm going
to run this and we're going to get two
things on here one we're going to get an
error and two we're going to get a
warning let's see what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says I need to read a
file and when this was written the
person who wrote it this is their path
where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and this
can be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches and
then they decided to keep one of those
and eventually get rid of the other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file because it's a
comma separated variable file and in a
spreadsheet this is what it looks like
as a basic text file you can see at the
top they've created a header and it's
got one two three four five columns and
each column has data in it and let me
flip this over because we're also going
to look at this in an actual spreadsheet
so you can see what that looks like and
here I've opened it up in the open
Office calc which is pretty much the
same as Excel and zoomed in and you can
see we've got our columns and our rows
of data a little easier to read in here
we have a result yes yes no we have
initial payment last payment credit
score house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting the data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data.head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data and we always start with zero
so we have five lines we have zero one
two three four instead of one two three
four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with
the shape of a thousand long five wide
so we have five columns and we do the
full data head you can actually see what
this data looks like the initial payment
last payment credit scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree so in our
next step we're going to train and build
our data tree and to do that we need to
First separate the data out we're going
to separate into two groups so that we
have something to actually train the
data with and then we have some data on
the site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data and Y is going to
be the answer or the target you can look
at it source and Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data and the second one says we're only
going to look at columns one through
five remember always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not so we want
to start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case when we set
the clf entropical decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play Within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this tutorial able to go through all of
these and how they work but we're
working on entropy that's one of the
options we've added that it's completely
a random state of 100 so 100 percent and
we have a max depth of three now the max
depth if you remember above when we were
doing the different graphs of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops and then we have
minimal samples of leaves is five so
it's going to have at least five leaves
at the end so I'll have at least three
splits or have no more than three layers
and at least five end leaves with the
final result at the bottom now that
we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go ahead and apply it
and see what that looks like so let's go
ahead and make a prediction and see what
that looks like we're going to paste our
predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here we
have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the SK learn modules that
they're different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case so we need
to test out the data and just see how
good our sample is how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
is works as a command line for python we
can simply put the why predict en to
print it I could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
now we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
a decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not
how does a random Forest work as a whole
so to begin our random Forest classifier
let's say we already have built three
trees and we're going to start with the
first tree that looks like this just
like we did in the example this tree
looks at the diameter if it's greater
than or equal to three it's true
otherwise it's false so one side goes to
the smaller diameter one side goes to
larger diameter and if the color is
orange it's going to go to the right
true we're using oranges now instead of
lemons and if it's red it's going to go
to the left false we build a second tree
very similar but split differently
instead of the first one being split by
a diameter this one when they created it
if you look at that first Bowl it has a
lot of red objects so it says is the
color red because that's going to bring
our entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three e is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false it goes off to the left if
it's true it goes off to the right let's
go ahead and bring these three trees you
can see them all in one image so this
would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe as a person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the the summer equals yes and
the shape is a circle and if you go to
the right you can look at what one of
the decision trees did this is the third
one is the diameter greater than equal
to three is a color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it say true and go
to the right tree two classifies it as
cherries is a color equal red is the
shape a circle true it is a circle so
this would look at it and say oh that's
a cherry and then we go to the other
classifier and it says is the diameter
equal one well that's false does it grow
in the summer true so it goes down and
looks at as oranges so how does this
random Forest work the first one says
it's an orange the second one said it
was a cherry and the third one says it's
an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry uh
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it I don't know
about you but I'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and I did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
oh this is the exciting part as we roll
up our sleeves and actually look at some
python coating before we start the
python coding we need to go ahead and
create a problem statement wonder what
species of Iris do these flowers belong
to let's try to predict the species of
the flowers using machine learning in
Python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and Implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into Python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case I'm going to be using the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter nope
book and I've already opened up a new
page for Python 3 code and I'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets import load Iris now
this isn't the actual data this is just
the module that allows us to bring in
the data the load Iris and the iris is
so popular it's been around since 1936
when Ronald Fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import our random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules and these are probably
the most commonly used modules in Python
and data science with any of the other
modules that we bring in and one is
going to be pandas we're going to import
pandas as PD p is a common term used for
pandas and pandas is basically creates a
data format for us where when you create
a pandas data frame it looks like an
Excel spreadsheet and you'll see that in
a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code panda is just wonderful
because it plays nice with all the other
modules in there and then we have numpy
which is our numbers Python and the
numbers python allows us to do different
mathematical sets on here we'll see
right off the bat we're going to take
our NP and we're going to go ahead and
Seed the randomness with it with zero so
np.random.seed is seating that as zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because I need to make sure I have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember I told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the Imports now I'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the IRS
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable Iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the DF to
Define data frame
and that's going to equal PD and if you
remember that's pandas as PD so that's
our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data and columns equals
Irish feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our DF has created what looks like
an Excel spreadsheet and in this Excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and I'm going to go print
I'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print olivirus
and see what that looks like
so when I print all a virus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length simple width
petal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names uh the target names which
is further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the Head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and Panda data frames
is when you do DF dot head or the panda
dataframe dot head it'll print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have them
in this case we have the column header
set to Iris features and in here you'll
see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in Python
most arrays always start at zero so when
you look at the first five it's going to
be zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our IRS
data imported into a data frame let's
take a look at the next piece of code in
here and so in this section here of the
code we're going to take a look at the
Target and let's go ahead and get this
into our notebook this piece of code so
we can discuss it a little bit more in
detail so here we are in our jupyter
notebook I'm going to put the code in
here and before I run it I want to look
at a couple things going on so we have a
DF species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where I
have DF species in Brackets which is the
key code for creating another column and
here we have iris.target now these are
both in the pandas setup on here so in
pandas we can do either one I could have
just as easily done Iris and then in
Brackets Target depending on what I'm
working on both are
extable run this is what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our our neural
network to look for these this different
data and know what a setosa is or a Vera
color which we'll see in just a minute
or virginica those are the three that
are in there and now we're going to add
one more column I know we're organizing
all this data over and over again it's
kind of fun there's a lot of ways to
organize it what's nice about putting
everything onto one data frame is I can
then do a printout and it shows me
exactly what I'm looking at and I'll
show you that where you where that's
different where you can alter that and
do it slightly differently but let's go
ahead and put this into our script up to
that now and here we go we're going to
put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it DF remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals NP remember
that stands for numpy DOT random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length DF comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take 75 percent of the data roughly
because there's a Randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 percent we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def.head
which prints the first five rows and
we've added a column is train at the end
and so we're going to take that we're
going to create two variables we're
going to create two new data frames
one's called train one's called test 75
percent in train 25 in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing DF our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it and if DF is trained equals
true
that's going to go in the train and if
DF is training equals false it goes in
the test and so when I run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and let's make it readable to
humans I don't know about you but I hate
looking at zeros and ones so let's start
with the features and let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF columns
and we know the first four of them 0 1 2
3 that'd be the first four are going to
be the features or the titles of those
columns and so when I run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing I want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's Jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the a terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when I run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about Jupiter notebooks
is I'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to PD dot factorize train species of
zero so let's break this down just a
little bit we have our pandas right here
PD factorize what is factorize doing I'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is and why we're looking at the group
zero on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this and we created this whole
column here for species
and then it has cytosis cytosis cytosis
cytosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and Vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end and then species is just that
column factorize goes in there and looks
at the fact that there's only three of
them so when I run this you'll see that
y generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go we have two
lines of code oh my goodness that was a
lot of work to get to two lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into our full
script that we're running and let's
paste this in here and let's take a look
and see what this is we have we're
creating a variable clf and we're going
to set this equal to the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals two if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf dot fit
so we're fitting we're training it we
are actually creating our random Forest
classifier right here this is a code
that does everything and we're going to
take our training set remember we kept
our test off to the side and we're going
to take our training set with the
features and then we're going to go
ahead and put that in and here's our
Target the Y so the Y is 0 1 and 2 that
we just created and the features is the
actual data going in that we put into
the training set let's go ahead and run
that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random Forest
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random State equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these the different
meanings of all these different settings
on here some of them are
self-explanatory if you kind of think
about it a little bit like Max features
is auto so all the features that we're
putting in there is just going to
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features because
you're processing words there might be
like 1.4 million features in there
because you're doing legal documents and
that's how many different words are in
there at that point you probably want to
limit the maximum features that you're
going to process in leaf nodes that's
the end notes remember we had the fruit
and we're talking about the leaf nodes
like I said there's a lot in this we're
looking at a lot of stuff here so you
might have in this case there's probably
only think three leaf nodes maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay you can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this and
that really is what most of these are
about is limiting